my career as an entrepreneur started at
10 years old 10 years old in Germany
when I had the desire I wanted to buy
this new Super Nintendo that was coming
I were living in the refugee camp my
mother doesn't have any money my father
parents go through divorce we have no
money to buy the Super Nintendo but I
really wanted right so I go to the local
pool they had this beautiful pool in
Erlangen Germany phenomenal pooling
their Lanka Germany and I go over there
and I'm trying to figure out a way to
make two hundred and forty nine marks to
buy the Super Nintendo right so I go to
the pool and I go to the owner and I
said look I noticed everywhere
everywhere I look at there's beers
everywhere I said luck what do you do
with all these beers all over the place
he says well I have to hire somebody go
and clean how much you pay the guy I'm
10 years old so I told him I said how
much will you give me if I clean up
every single one of them how much will
you give me per each that I bring to you
he said five fennec ker beer bottle five
fennec is like five pennies per beer
bottle well I did the math and I said
how much do I need I need around five
thousand Fenig which means a thousand
beer bottles to me roughly equals me
getting myself you know this what he
call it this supernatant that I want to
buy so whatever the number was I think
was a five hundred twenty-five hundred
bill but yeah five thousand beer bottles
that I collect gets me this super Newton
that I want to buy he said sure well I
started doing it I would come through
collect and put in about put it over
here
boom six marks in one day eight marks in
one day twelve marks on one day ten
marks in one day next thing you know the
entire pool knew me as the ten year old
skinny Middle Eastern kid that collects
beer bottles and everyone say hey
Patrick hey Patrick hey V gets heavy
gets and I start they thought I was an
employee at ten years old and eventually
I made my 300 marks and I went to Cal
father and I bought my Super Nintendo so
how are you taking serious as an
entrepreneur a young entrepreneur well
first things first if you come to me as
a young entrepreneur you find a solution
to problem I'm interested okay doesn't
matter how old you are if you find me a
solution to a problem I'm interested
solution to problem number two know more
than anybody else does
listen look at Kobe Bryant as an
entrepreneur okay
Kobe Bryant as an entrepreneur he is a
basketball player his product is him he
plays basketball he gets paid a hundred
million dollar contract at 20 years old
at 18 years old three million dollar
contract 10 million not whatever the
number is why because he knows more
about the game than everybody else his
age so people pay for him in your
business if your real estate insurance
financial services technology so
whatever it is no more than anybody else
in your marketplace because you
absolutely immerse yourself into the
subject that you're selling and know
more than anybody else everybody listens
to you it doesn't matter how old you are
because you know a lot about that
specific subject next point start at the
bottom and get dirty look at there's a
certain thing that if you want to be
taken serious I like back in the days
when people work for a company everybody
started off selling and then they came
to the top right and everybody kind of
know how to sell because then you know
how to connect with every single
position where someone says we don't
know what it is to be a Salesman what do
you talk about I sold for seven years we
don't know what it is to do is what do
you tell me came I came from the bottom
to the top there is something special
about a person a young person a young
entrepreneur willing to get their hands
dirty and learning when I started
working at one of the jobs it was at
Bally Total Fitness and they send me to
sell memberships
at a mall in Fox Hills Mall Kover City
and I went out and I'm selling
memberships to people in the mall that
are walking by 36 month contract well I
went I got my hands dirty came up I
became rookie dear we want triple crown
got a big claw became a manager and I'm
boom good stuff started happening for me
I took that same principle everywhere so
be willing to start at the bottom and
work your way up next one have a good
reputation have a good reputation what I
mean by that nowadays on Facebook if you
have a facebook picture with a beer bong
you're no one's going to take you
serious the other day somebody sent me a
message literally I wish I could show
this pictures picture to you send me a
message hey I'd like to work for you
okay
I'd like to work for you great we're
always looking for people to hire I like
to work for you I'll travel from New
York and I'll come and work for you for
free for six months I just want to learn
from you I looked at his profile picture
it's him sleeping with his head
is knocked out that's that you're
marketing yourself as somebody lazy have
a good reputation people nowadays that
do business with you they looked at look
at your LinkedIn they look at your
Facebook they look at your Twitter they
look at everything about you you got to
have a clean reputation if you want to
be taken serious as an entrepreneur
because other people how are other
people gonna say things about you if I
call somebody done business with and if
you don't give me references that's a
red flag right off the bat if I hire
somebody that wants to do business with
me or they want to sell me the product
and service and they're not willing to
give me reference to call on somebody I
don't necessarily take you that serious
because there's probably reason why you
are not willing to give me any kind of a
reference Nate next make money if you're
if you're 19 years old and you're making
130 per year people automatically want
to know how you're making 130 per year
period if you're 21 years old making 290
per year people want to listen to you
now someone say to nine you pretty what
do you total makes that kind of money
many young entrepreneurs how can they
make that kind of money they outwork you
they know more they want more they're
more competitive than you simple as that
well that's not fair Patrick it's not
all about hard work it has a lot to do
with hard work research diligence
immerse but making more money gets other
people to take you serious when you
yourself are making more money next one
have a real opinion backed up by some
facts so if I'm having a conversation I
sat down with a kid the other day I call
him a kid but he's not a kid 22 year old
a kid that comes to my office and he's
sitting there wanting to sell me
commercial real estate he may be
watching this if it's you and he starts
talking to me and I said you're very
comfortable in your own skin tell me a
little bit about your parents and he
starts talking about his mom I said tell
me about your father and he talks about
his father and I said you're in
commercial real estate I am I said I
want to know what are some things your
father taught you well my dad taught me
about hard working from being born to 12
I was my mama's boy from 12 on I was
just so curious I wanted to be around my
dad because I want to learn from my dad
etc etc and I said you know would you
learn from sales I'm a new commercial he
said I thought so from talking to him
and I asked him opinions about
capitalism and iScan pinions about
economics he had an opinion and I sat
and I said he's a 21 22 year old kid I
would do business with them
he reminds me of me when I was first
getting started and I have an opinion
about something that's validated by
facts not just some general thing I have
an opinion because I watch something on
CNN MSNBC or Fox a real sense of opinion
people respect when someone has a real
opinion about certain facts next one ask
for responsibility
I just love where people ask for
responsibility you know you work at a
place hey what do you I'm going to do
what do you need from me tell me how can
I help you I was working with this lady
who she was my superior she was my
manager my boss for seven years and
every time I would work I would say hey
is there anything I can help you with
what else do you need help on how can I
help you how can I do anything what can
I do with you so what can I do with this
it was always I want more responsibility
I want more responsibility - what kind
of responsibility can you give me I want
more I want more because that puts me in
positions the more responsibilities I
take in the more I'm delivering on my
responsibilities it's not just taking it
or not delivering its delivering on the
responsibilities you take then people
start taking you more serious on who you
are next deliver and keep your word look
I cannot tell you I cannot tell you how
much value there is we give a lot of
credit to people that have great credit
score's 800 credit score's will give you
a million dollar loan here to go buy a
house will give you seventy thousand
dollar loan here to go buy that car as
important as your FICO scores there is a
credit score I pay attention to more
than your FICO score if I got some
people that are working here with me as
my team or leaders are mentoring and I
ask him for something
what can I count on you I can do XYZ
they don't do it I don't value their
word because their credit score with
their award is not that high with me so
whatever they say the next time I take
50% of it because I don't trust their
word anymore so here's a CEO
entrepreneur that no longer trust the
word of somebody that says what they're
going to do if you want to be taken
serious as a young entrepreneur make
commitments keep commitments let your
word be so powerful that even though
you're 19 years old I know you're going
to deliver when I give you a challenge
on something to do next dress sharp you
know a lot of times nowadays with Steve
Jobs in a dress sharp and Mark
Zuckerberg didn't read straw Brett
cetera et cetera fine if you're
producing software and you're behind the
scenes
nobody sees you you don't have to be
dressed sharp I get it but if you come
and meet with somebody else it generally
helps to be dressed sharp than somebody
that's not dressed sharp you got to know
how to put it together your supper
clothes it doesn't cost a lot of money
nowadays to put it together I remember
when I first got started my goodness I
bought so much stuff from goodwill in
goodwill of second-hand suits and
jackets I don't come from a family of
money so was goodwill
it was DSW shoes on sale on sale on sale
he was $9 ties from Ross it was three
nine dollar white shirts from Ross and
it was a jacket that was ripped here I
couldn't go like this because people
could tell it was a whole thing rip I
couldn't pay the guys 60 bucks to fix
both sides ripped like this high waters
because the jacket was a smaller and I'm
65 and everybody would see this I have
to talk like this but I made sure I got
that because I wanted to make sure
people took me serious as a 21 22
year-old entrepreneur next one listen
listen listen to people who have had
success that are giving you feedback
listen to them listen to what they're
telling you take counsel from people
that have which you don't have lifestyle
listen to it people realize you there's
a certain level of wisdom that a young
person has who is willing to listen to
counsel from somebody that has already
been someplace they haven't been I'm not
talking about taking everyone's advice
if someone's been married thirty plus
years and has three good kids and they
themselves would perform at a high level
in their personal life and they became
very successful so they have good
marriage good kids good family life good
a financial life successful life you
probably won't take some counsel from
them if somebody's in a business that
you're part of and they've made certain
income and they've done it at a level
the proper way and you can learn from
them listen it's probably good counsel
you want to take from them 11 be the
first to show up last to leave quite
frankly if you don't have any kids
you're an 18 year old kid you're 19
years old you're 20 years old what else
do you have to do unless showing up
early and leaving late what are you
going to do go home and do what go to a
party go to a club go smoke hookah for
what you want you want to just be a
small-time person or you want to be
somebody that's going to perform if you
want to be someone that's going to
perform at a high level show up very
early
stay very late let people know you're
out there hustling because you're the
first or
arrived last to leave act yours above a
beyond your yours meaning act beyond
your yours what do I mean by that you
know think about if you're 21 how does a
31 year old act like who's already where
you want to be walk talk think like that
person how does that person that's
already there you want to be so I would
sit then I would say okay Pat you're 22
years old right now yes how was the 30
version 30 year old version of Patrick
way they were gonna be and I would walk
like that Patrick with David I would
want to think like that Patrick wait
David how would he speak how would he
talk how would he do this
how would he close how would it be how
nervous would he be and I would try to
put myself as an eight year old advance
Patrick big baby and then performing
come from that place yourself next
surround yourself with people that are
way ahead of you that's pretty simple
listen I've always had people that are
much smarter than me much wiser than me
you know better a lifestyle they me way
ahead of me alive they're giving me
counsel people that are absolutely way
way way ahead of me in any area of my
life that I specifically want because I
learned from them and they push me and
they challenge me to constantly get
better another one is avoid drugs it's
pretty simple I am definitely not a fan
of drugs I know there's a lot of things
people read where this person said LSD
and that person said you know this drug
and that person said this you know
whoever that person is that said they
have no clue what the hell they're
talking about I'm not a fan of drugs
I've seen too many of my good friends
had one very very good friend who was
sharper than any one of us he started
off with pot then he went on Special K
LSD coke you know heroin you go every
single thing vicodin xanax everything
and eventually it's the pills that ends
up killing you one of the hardest drugs
to get off of nowadays isn't heroin it's
vicodin its xanax as those pills that
put you to sleep and you don't feel
anything so I just don't recommend any
drugs I heard a person one time that
worked for me and she came to work the
first day the second time she came to
work I pulled her aside and I said hey
are you okay and she said what do you
mean I said just look at me my eyes are
you okay and I've been around drugs you
know people have had problems with that
so I said you sure you okay and
says hey hey I'm okay I said look at me
I've been around what's up and fixing
you know she gets embarrassed and she
leaves anyways she leaves you're later
she calls me comes and meets with me
cries breaks down and tells me while I
was working with you I was taking pills
and she would come to work and all these
symptoms that I would study no one's
going to hire and maintain somebody like
that in life you got to drop the drug so
why am I talking about drugs it's a very
common thing with kids nowadays - it's
always been the case pop X I'm rolling
I'm doing this I'm doing that if you
have any plans of doing anything big why
would you add other things in your life
that slows you down there is no reason
for doing that I don't drink coffee
because coffee you know you know people
get connected to coffee I don't need
coffee I exercise to get my energy I
don't need to drink coffee now some
people do and some people do that I'm
not offended but I'm simply giving you
my opinions on what it is to be taken
serious as a young entrepreneur avoid
drugs avoid any of that stuff and
eventually people will notice you
advance in their life and your brain is
going to be functioning from a good
place you're not going to mess yourself
up you're not going to make any of those
big mistakes in life that really set you
back and all of a sudden you notice
everyone around you wants to do business
with you you're making good income
you're traveling the world you're
becoming an influencer and you're doing
well in life and your clients your
customers love doing business with you
and your dreams are becoming a reality
because now people are taking you
serious as a young entrepreneur and no
age has nothing to do with being taken
serious nothing I can look at a kids
eyes and know that kid is really
determined about what they want to do in
their lives eyes never lie when you do
business with somebody they can tell
from the eyes if it's droopy if it's all
over the place and if you know exactly
the subject you're speaking on that
brings confidence so anyways that's my
message to you on how to be taken as a
serious as a young entrepreneur if you
know another young entrepreneur you want
to share this content with them go ahead
and do so if you got any questions
comment on the bottom if you haven't
subscribed to this channel subscribe to
the channel we got a lot more great
content on the channel they can find as
well thanks for watching
you